it was a wild week in north american
valerian sentinels were forced to play
with some subs nismo looks like the best
player on the planet and there were
quite a few upsets
but with only two weeks remaining almost
every team still has a shot at playoffs
even sentinels so let's talk about it
before we get into the video i just want
to remind you guys about liz's navct
watch parties every friday saturday and
sunday you can come hang out with her
and some special guests live on our
twitch channel while they watch all of
the matches
no
no
[Music]
bro literally all lined up
all right week three of the na vct group
stage is over and although every match
ended in a 2-0 we actually have a lot to
talk about now i know sentinels haven't
exactly had the best start to stage two
hell they've been on a steady decline
basically since their win in iceland
last year but they're still the most
popular valent roster in the whole world
so let's talk about them first sentinels
played optic on saturday and what was
pretty much a must-win match since
taking home the masters one trophy optic
have picked up exactly where they left
off and they're still yet to lose a
series so it was already an uphill
battle for sentinels but to make matters
worse they made a surprising
announcement just about an hour before
the match even got underway they tweeted
that tens was sick and sick had a family
emergency so they'd be subbing in their
coach raucous who also had kovid and my
boy danny now i spoke to danny yesterday
and it turns out that he had just as
much notice as us on saturday i think
they asked me an hour and a half before
the match started like i was actually
about to leave my house
to watch the champions league final and
then chaz was messing me like that they
need a sub
and i couldn't say no so
it was an hour and a half before as
expected optic won 2-0 to remain
undefeated and sentinels are still
winless now before this match i would
have told you that they needed a win
here to keep their season alive they're
not mathematically out of contention for
playoffs but they're in desperate need
of some wins sentinels did give us an
update late last night stating that sick
will be taking an extended leave of
absence to attend to an ongoing family
matter so raucous will fill in for the
remainder of challengers i hope
everything's alright was sick luckily
for them and unfortunately for me my
team c9 build them out a bit by getting
schmidt on by faze on sunday
the horse push comes through that's
poised with the null commander spanish
right through the smoke they're finding
the perfect angles the drop down it's
not coordinated with anything coverage
from the back baby bay
is straight up breaking ankles cloud9's
loss to phase really makes things
interesting though group b is
essentially wide open if sentinels win
their two remaining matches against both
of those teams then they have a solid
chance of qualifying but the most
interesting team in group b at least to
me is eg they stomped lg on the weekend
and i gotta be honest i did not see this
coming and i definitely wasn't the only
one giagamo and bustio continued to frag
out as they always do but what impressed
me the most was calm's fade on map 2.
just take a look at some of these
utility combos doctors step it up but he
fights it very well here on the attacker
side of long b but there's a counter
from the orbital strike on the defense
so apot drops a spike there's only 12
seconds left in the round b and argued
as we'll have to hold it down 10 seconds
left the plant's coming in and joshua's
pushing inside the side she'll stop her
off to the ground it's a two versus one
dazzles at five hp as they're moving in
on to the defuse where eg dodges the
paint shells the swing out as jogimo
gets the kill and eg another clean round
as they get 5-0 although we've seen each
region test out fade on various maps i
wouldn't really call her a must-pick
agent just yet but here's eg's coach
potter talking about the fade pick fate
is just so strong right now the utility
the info um and the great thing about
fate is he's just she's just another sky
at any point you can just swap and
switch your role from an initiator to a
duelist um that kit allows it right and
so we saw a little bit of a breach
coming through and it was great while it
lasted but fade is just so much better
all right let's move on to group a where
the fight for playoffs is even tighter
first i want to start off with the guard
after a disappointing run in iceland
they tried to reinvent themselves we saw
some roll swaps throughout the first
couple weeks of stage two and things
just weren't working but thankfully this
past week the guard went back to their
roots sayo was on jet again and trent
was doing well
trent things
well timing here for trent it's gonna be
everything it's an even exchange
pinstripe goes to kill feed 3v2 numbers
with tsm but the clock is not in their
favor they've collected the spike trent
comes forward trying to stop the plant
from even coming through in the first
place and takes down all four
next let's talk about hunter thieves
they kind of [ __ ] on accent which i
didn't see coming the young guns asana
bang and will all popped off and with
this win they're now sitting at the top
of group a with a better map win and
round differential than both exit and
ghost speaking of ghosts they're the
real deal guys the team that everyone
expected to see back in stage 1 finally
seemed to have it figured
out to keep checking their back they
have to be ready for something what a
flashback both three kills looking for
the fourth and he's gonna get it he
tries to answer back and already at 19
hp nismo continues to look unstoppable
with a bald buff a restaurant buff and
even a dad buff this dude is basically
the johnny sins of valerian his
opponents nrg on the other hand were
pretty disappointing if i'm being honest
but they did try out something somewhat
interesting since each and every member
of ghost used the vandal they decided to
only purchase light armor throughout the
entire game that way they could ensure
themselves more buy rounds because if
you get one tap by a vandal then you're
dead and it doesn't matter how much army
you have so do i think this was a cool
idea
yeah i guess did it work out though
no not at all
not at all
but like i said earlier the race for
playoffs is extremely close in both
groups optic is the only team who i can
really say is a cut above the rest right
now and the rest of the competition in n
a is nuts it seems like any team can win
on any day whoever shows up on the match
day just deserves it more but with only
two spots for copenhagen up for grabs it
genuinely makes me sad to think of all
the teams that are going to have their
season cut short in the next couple
weeks and this isn't just a problem in n
a no the vct season will be ending for
many teams worldwide because of this
year's format which is insane because
it's only june i wish riot would give us
more international lands or at least
expand the amount of teams that are at
current events there are just so many
good teams out there who deserve a
chance but with regional leagues coming
next year and rumors of only eight to
ten teams getting invites it's tough for
me to stay optimistic and it's even
scarier for some of the pros this could
really harm the development of the tier
two scene when i see all these rumors
about like the the format for the league
i'm like oh like if there's only like
four to six and a team it's gonna be
tough because
like right now the top 10 are all good
every month there's someone new that
pops off or there's a meta that favors
that team so it's kind of like it's
whoever adapts the hardest and adapts
the most
and um
yeah it's like it's very tight right now
like anything can happen now there is
still time for riot to maybe expand some
of these leagues and change some things
for next year but for a lot of teams
their 2022 seasons are about to end
it was a wild week in north american
valor i feel like i'm [ __ ] sweating i
should take off this sweater or i'm
gonna power through
do i look like i'm sweating hang on saya
was on jet again and trent was well
doing trend things
oh trent
trent moment for a lot of teams their
2022 seasons are about to end that is
getting heavy damn
it's sad
sag i wrote saj in the script beside
that